ilan movie of the washington post is a
financial reporter there and she is here
to discuss
Black Friday consumer spending and the
Christmas holiday season Elan Mui how
important is today to our economy today
is hugely important to our economy last
year shoppers spent 11 billion dollars
on Black Friday alone so this is a very
big shopping day the holiday season
overall accounts for anywhere from
twenty to forty percent of total retail
sales for the year so this is a very
very big season for it for stores and
they want to make sure that they don't
get it wrong so why do we spend so much
on this one day what I mean is it just
tradition well that's part of it you
know the Black Friday typically kicks
off the holiday shopping season but
there's also obviously retailers play a
big part in this they're offering the
doorbuster discounts at 5 a.m. at
midnight all throughout the day so that
gets us into the stores and helps us
pull out a little bit of money from our
wallets now a lot stores seem to be open
yesterday yes it's the first time well
it's the first time for some stores
really this trend began last year but we
saw more stores sort of join in on it
I'm Kmart's traditionally been open on
Thanksgiving Day but this year we also
saw Toys R Us opening at 10:00 p.m.
Sears open at 7:00 a.m. old navy open
about a 850 stores on Thanksgiving Day
so what we're really finding is that
some of the Black Friday excitement is
moving farther into the month moving
even into Thanksgiving Day itself what
are the predictions for spending this
holiday season the most cited prediction
is from the National Retail Federation
and they're expecting sales to be up 2.3
percent for November and December
compared to last year but the forecasts
typically are all over the place the
National Retail Federation's is sort of
in the middle I've seen forecasts as
high as four percent increase over last
year so we are expecting consumers to
return to the stores as holiday 2:02 is
the area code we are talking about
retail sales consumer spending and
potentially government policy to
encourage such 7:37 triple zero to for
democrats 737 triple zero one for
Republicans and six to eight zero
2:05 for all others Elan Mui is our
guest she's with the Washington Post a
financial reporter if spending doesn't
increase as predicted what's the
downside the downside is that consumer
spending first of all accounts for about
two-thirds our total GDP so it's very I
know think about that two-thirds of our
GDP is a turn by how much we go to the
mall right so this is very important
what we saw in previous years when
consumers pulled back and let's say 2008
during the depths of the financial
crisis as we saw a lot of job loss come
January and February retailers shed
thousands of jobs because we weren't
seeing the demand to justify those
positions in their stores so you can
find that if people don't come out and
shop you might see a dent employment
rate increase now there are some key
consumer economic indicators that I want
to review with you before we get to
calls number one consumer confidence up
71 point six percent err up to 71 point
six percent what is consumer confidence
how is it measured I'm assuming that
you're referring to a study that's done
every month by the University of
Michigan and basically what they do is
they survey consumers and ask them how
do they feel about their personal
financial well-being what is their view
of the economy what is their a long-term
view and so they measure how consumers
feel about both their situation now and
what their situation will be in the
future and that gives us a sort of
rolling indicator to see you know are we
starting to feel better or are we
starting to sort of go back into the
gloomy days of the recession and the
fact that consumers are feeling a little
bit better you know speaks well to what
they might spend during holidays so a
consumer confidence rating of 71 percent
or 71 what does that say that tells me
that consumers are feeling better I'm a
bad number a bad number here would be
something in the 50s or something even
below that and we saw some of that
during the depths of the recession so
there has been a rebound but we still
aren't back to the level that we would
like to see holiday spending forecast up
2.3 percent who makes that forecast and
that one comes from the National Retail
Federation again they are a tree
so you have to understand where where
your data is coming from but they are
one of the most widely cited stats for
what the holidays will see and they are
actually one of the more moderate
predictions for this holiday personal
income is up a half a percent disposable
personal income up a third of a percent
wages and salaries up about half a
percent and personal savings up 5.7
percent does our economy in the way it's
structured with 2/3 being going to the
mall as you said does it encourage
saving well typically it hasn't during
the boom years we found that the savings
rate in some months actually was
negative so America was spending more
than we actually had in our wallets and
that's not a good thing I mean obviously
that's not sustainable now we're at a
point where consumers are trying to
rebalance that and trying to sort of set
their financial house in order so the
good news is that people are saving more
the bad news for the economy is that if
they're saving more that means that
they're spending less do we know are
people looking to use cash or credit for
this holiday season and doesn't matter
it does matter actually study after
study has shown that when consumers buy
things on credit when they charge their
on their credit cards they tend to spend
more money so that is a very important
indicator for retailers
however we are finding this year more
people are trying to use cash because
they don't want to spend more money on
their credit cards so they're using cash
as a way to sort of help balance their
budget and make sure they stay on track
ilan Mui is our guest from the
Washington Post numbers are on the
screen we're talking about consumer
spending retail sales and if you want to
tell us what your plans are for this
holiday season please do so Cara Lynn
Newland North Carolina on a Republican
line your first stop hi good morning
folks how are you good ma'am I'm not
going to try to pronounce your name I
got two questions one is who's going to
take the hit is it going to be the
manufacturer the consumer or the
distributor and the fact that our dollar
is taking a hit and my second question
is why do you think that consumers are B
core now
they were say two three months ago
alright so I'll take your first question
first I think what we're seeing in terms
of the lower value of the dollar I think
right now it's hurting the manufacturer
the most in terms of for American
products that makes a you know that
makes our products less less attractive
overseas so I think that you know the
consumer will actually benefit if
perhaps in the terms of lower prices
that you may see the manufacturer being
hit for the second part of your question
why our consumer is feeling a little bit
better one reason that we found is the
stock market is better so stock market
is much better than it was a few months
ago we've written a recent rally so that
helps a lot of people sort of feel
better about their finances they may
feel they may see their 401 K their
retirement plans coming back and you're
also seeing the economy actually add
jobs I know the unemployment rate hasn't
changed but that's sort of an accounting
an accounting issue we're actually
seeing a private-sector jobs increase in
recent months and so you are seeing some
return to the job market some some more
movement there and that's making folks
feel a little bit better as well next
call comes from Annapolis Maryland
Edie independent line hi how are you
doing
thank you for c-span my parents were
products of the depression and I
remember I'm 72 I remember as a child
almost all of my presence my parents
made I would recommend that instead of
buying stuff from China where they're
ripping us off anyhow that we start
making some of our own stuff there's
nothing better than knitting your own
sweater I mean my father even had molds
to make his you know tin soldiers so
that's a real alternative yeah sure
thank you for your thoughts and I think
that there are a lot of people who are
going to be making their own gifts this
holiday season that was definitely a
trend that we saw because of our session
folks trying to save money by by DIY
doing it yourself you know movie what if
expectations here's the New York Times
business section article Black Friday
expectations are high
what happens if expectations are not met
you know one year we did have a very odd
situation
where the traffic to the malls into the
stores increased but sales on Black
Friday actually decreased and the reason
that happened was because retailers were
pulling out such aggressive discounting
that even though people bought more they
spent less overall so you know I think
that retailers really looked to Black
Friday as sort of an indicator of how
the rest of the season will go you know
is this going to be something good is
this going to be a situation where we're
going to be in the black or is it not
and it says in this article mall traffic
this year is up by more than 12 percent
it also says in the New York Times a
cached Christmas about 90% of Americans
plan to use cash for their holiday gifts
this year and that's according to a
survey from the United services
Automobile Association which provides
insurance to military members and their
families next call Sweetwater Texas
Charlie Democrat you are on with Elon
mooie of the Washington Post thank you
sir appreciate the c-span very much I've
been watching you all three years thank
you and ma'am I like to ask you a
question or make a point with your way
you won't take it
you said the shopping center holidays
were really good for the economy whose
economy you're talking about because you
can go in the store you can't hold a pad
anything made in America so how does the
American people well
yeah I think that what we've seen over
the years is that the American consumer
drives the global economy not just our
economy but it does help if you go into
a retail store likely it's a retail
store that is based in the u.s.
obviously Walmart stores if you look at
them they've been criticized in the past
for the amount of foreign products they
carry but they are headquartered in
Bentonville Arkansas I wrote a story
recently as well about an employee here
in the Virginia area who works in an
electronic store at ETH Gregg and he
works on commission
so his fate is directly tied to the
amount that consumers spend when they
come in the store now you can argue
about how much you should be spending
this holiday season but certainly he's
feeling a direct impact on how much
consumers will be spending and that was
a front-page story if I could recall
correctly a couple of month or so back
have you followed up with him to see how
sales are you know I haven't talked to
him recently but the last time that I
did which was I think about a week after
I first spent time with him you know
it's really a it's non predictable you
know there were some days where he sold
you know maybe a TV or two and one day
you hit it big and sold ten thousand
dollars worth of product so you know it
can be a very tough field and it's it's
all dependent on a little bit of luck
and a little bit of skill what's what
are the top items this holiday season or
what are they predicting to be the top
items is holiday season well one item
that we see surging this year is jewelry
and we're seeing jewelry sales come back
as a luxury consumer comes back and this
is not hitting my husband at all but
we're also seeing electronics always a
hot product and you know retailers
typically discount electronics because
that's something that excites consumers
and helps get them through the door and
then every tailors are hoping that they
buy other things as well and obviously
toys toys are very big this year we have
the Justin Bieber doll which has just
launched this Black Friday at Toys R Us
and there's some other toys as well such
as thingamajigs and the Big Foot monster
okay chances are Justin Bieber doll is
not made in the United States Justin
Bieber all I know for a fact is not made
in the United States so somebody buys a
Justin Bieber doll who benefits how does
that $12.99 $15.99 what
how does that break down do you know can
you give us a kind of initiation I can't
give you an exact breakdown but what I
can tell you is that you know many
retail products are typically marked up
about 50 percent right so if you buy
something at full price if I buy this
blouse at full price let's say 50
percent of that of that doll of that
amount is going toward the retailer um
so that gives them a certain amount of
margin to work with to be able to
discount products you know where the
rest of that 50 percent of the products
price goes it varies I mean there's a
lot of competition among retailers to
pay the least amount for the raw goods
or the materials that are coming over
from overseas next call for Ilan Mui
comes from Orlando Florida go ahead
Steve all right good morning how are you
good I'm commenting about the retail
sales I'm a plumbing supply salesman I
travel Florida Georgia and Alabama the
retail sales right now for a Black
Friday may look great but there they are
sale prices you have to use a coupon or
a giveaway to get these people in the
store
these sales this morning really do not
count because the American people have
been suffering I go into my customers
everyday you can stand there for an hour
to they'll give me an order but no
customers will come in the door now I
understand it's a plumbing supply and
it's not a popular item during the
Christmas season but people have been
struggling all year long and if they're
going to count on this one Black Friday
that's going to guide them through to
Christmastime they're in them they're in
a fantasy lab there is no way that we
can sit here and say that one day is
going to be great for the rest of the
year he has put so many rules and
restrictions this Democratic Congress
and his Democratic president in front of
us that small business people appealing
it so one day is not going to make a
difference out of 10 days now what I
would say is that I think that he's
really speaking to one of the issues
that we're finding is that there is a
bifurcation in terms of how consumers
are feeling right now and how we're
spending right now we're finding that
the pace of economic recovery is not the
same across a different economic classes
so there's been a lot talked about in
terms of the luxury retailer coming back
we said like we just said jewelry is up
this year
and luxury retailers doing well but the
flip side of that is that for the middle
and low income consumer they actually
have been harder hit in terms of
unemployment and they're not as boosted
by the stock market as the affluent
consumer is so there's still a lot of
strain among the lower rungs of the
economic ladder and you can hear it from
the retailer's who serve that population
as well so let's say Sachs has a good
year and Walmart doesn't that's very
possible
is that good for the economy is that bad
for the economy what is it I think it
it's what is for the economy typically
you know there have been there have been
cases where the Athlon consumer is
considered sort of more significant in
terms of economic contribution the top
20% of incomes of income households
produce about 40% of total consumer
spending so their spending is outsized
in comparison to the amount that they
make about the population does that mean
that we should forget about the lower
the lower class in the middle class
obviously not but if you look at it
strictly from an economic sense that is
the imbalance that you see this tweet
from Obama game so they want us to spend
again great we learn nothing they want
us back in debt we learn nothing there
and there's something that economists
call the paradox of the rift right so
even though saving is good for us
personally it is not something that's
good for the economy overall and that's
the dilemma that we're facing right now
I think that most people would say we we
shouldn't go back to the days of
negative savings rate and the spending
of you know the the mid 2000s is really
unsustainable but what is that level of
sustainable growth that's what we're
trying to figure out now next call comes
from winston-salem North Carolina Diane
good morning good morning nice to talk
with you this morning or what c-span de
Lawd I was just calling in we are just
pretty much boycotting any kind of
shopping there's nothing been made in
the USA for oh my goodness we're
probably over 10 years all our jobs have
been shipped overseas so the Triad area
we are just boycotting any kind of
shopping at all no
any type of Christmas or anything we're
going to do that with our families hey
Diane do they do they still make
anything in winston-salem I know they
used to make cigarettes there a long
time ago do they still make cigarettes
there no sir RJ no sir RJ Reynolds no no
no that is moved out of North Carolina
has always been the furniture capital of
the world our furniture is made in China
our textiles are overseas this has been
going on for years so what we have
decided to do here is to boycott this
and the people of the Triad has are
going to boycott this we're not shopping
with the condition there's nothing made
in the USA
alright the jobs have been taken away
from us not under this presidency here
it's been taken away for years all right
we got the point well you know obviously
this issue of where where you buy your
products is a big one I'll tell you last
year my family and I made a very tough
decision to decide to not exchange
presents for the holiday season and I
think that part of that was driven by
the fact that it's a it's a tough time
economically for many folks and you know
for us as well we're all watching that
dollar but also because we felt like we
have enough stuff I think you know
there's sort of an anti Black Friday
movement called Buy Nothing day you know
where you just stay home and sing your
pajamas which sounds fun to me as well
and but but you know we made a decision
that we weren't gonna change holiday
gifts because we felt like we have
everything that we need and the most
important thing was to just get together
and spend time together as a family but
what does that do to the national
economy now that wasn't good for the
national economy again there's that
paradox of thrift next call Mary Ann
Chatham Virginia go ahead Mary good
morning I'm not gonna talk my question
is about the things we have do buy the
groceries the extra fees that are coming
from the government for license plates
the increases that we get letters from
utilities how does that figure into
your profit margin or what you expect it
doesn't equate at all to a better
economy well one thing that is positive
is that we've seen food prices decline
and and that's really something that's
very important for many consumers
particularly after the high levels of
food prices that we saw around 2008 so
food prices are down and that's good but
that is something that is very important
to look at is what is what is the price
of necessities such as food such as
gasoline and heating because those
things eat into the discretionary income
that we have to spend on things like a
new flat-screen TV a la movie what about
seasonal hiring for the holidays
seasonal hiring this year is expected to
be a little bit better than last year
about 500,000 600,000 workers are
expected to be added to the workforce
for the holiday season and that's down
from about 700 during the peak years and
let's say 2007 so that that is something
that is a bright spot for for the age
for the job market however he has
remembered their seasonal so come
January in February you might see that
being said does shopping online affect
this whole thing yes certainly shopping
online is a huge part of the holiday
season now and so we're expecting
holiday sales to rise about 11% on the
over the internet on online sales to
about 32 billion dollars this holiday
season so it is a huge portion it's
something that's very important and
something that's very convenient for a
lot of folks but does it help the
economy or does it hurt taking it away
from the bricks and mortar you know I
think that most retailers look at it as
all one big happy family these days you
know they're there they're considering
this multi-channel they look at bricks
and mortars they look at online they're
looking at mobile they're looking at by
maybe even through your iPad one day so
you know they're looking at it as a as a
unit as opposed to competing centers
Elon mooie is our guest here on the
Washington Journal this morning talking
about retail sales and consumer spending
Salina Kansas
go ahead Kyle good morning to you
hey how you doing good my comments just
kind of it's kind of probably how
everyone's feeling I'm just I'm really
disappointed that our products aren't
making spaces more like I can't I can't
buy anything like like okay four weeks
ago I wanted to buy a guitar well I got
online and bought a guitar when it came
to my house yeah there's a nice guitar
on a bus but still it was made in Korea
you know it wasn't made in the States if
it was made in the States it would cost
like you know two thousand dollars and
said Gibson on it well that's fine but I
just I wish things with what happened
great for this country and we need to
start thinking our progress if we need
to start making things here Kyle what
are your plans for this holiday season
I plan on doing my shop in between now
and Christmas but not like this weekend
right but I mean hummin do you plan on
spending more than you did last year do
you plan on using cash credit I mean as
far as being American I would say it's
best to go cash because look at what the
credit has got offensive but I was you
know hey you know if you want to break
the bank on mom's favorite outfit you're
gonna do it because she's your mom but
still I mean I'm probably gonna spend I
probably even say five to seven hundred
dollars which isn't nothing and what do
you know what you spent last year all
right thanks Kyle I think he brought up
a very good point which is there is a
conflict you know or a debate between
where you want your products be made and
the price that you were willing to pay
for those products so you know that's
one of the the challenges that we face
is that typically you know products that
are made overseas there's lower labor
costs so you can charge less for for
them in the stores so you know what
we're how much are you willing to pay
for products that are made in America
Twitter or maybe Mary Lou goes under
save Republic sends in this tweet as you
shop on Black Friday
don't forget to buy union check out a
list of goods made in America and she
has sent as well a link here that lists
and products made in the United States
and it the website is at UFC W dot o-r-g
in case you are interested Long Island
New York Dave you are on the line good
morning to you good morning I just had
to cook I guess when you're you were
speaking about the retail sales
representing I believe she said two
thirds DP I was uh I guess in that
context I know that we just printed I
guess they had two quantitative easing
too and we just printed like six hundred
billion dollars and I guess a big part
of that is to inflate asset at asset
prices and we need to speak about the
you know the equities market a lot of
that you know intentionally the
government to intentionally reflate the
stock market but doesn't that it's not
kind of lead to a UH like a you know a
misconception for people like a false
sense of you know like we're doing well
where is uh you know when they talk in
terms of misallocation of capital like
we think things are good so we're gonna
be more confident and spend more money
on Christmas but really well we did was
just a print print the money to me all
right Dave I didn't mean to cut you off
there go ahead you love me yeah what
what I would say is first of all the the
quantitative easing is taking place
throughout a period of I think six to
eight months so you know it's it's not
like there was suddenly six hundred
billion dollars that was wasn't there
before
the other thing to talk about is a lot
of that was already priced into the
stock market
so actually what we're finding now is
that other countries are upset with us
for going through quantitative easing
and and that has taken a hit on the
stock markets as well so you know there
there are many complex factors there but
there is a question of how confident
should we be in these economic policies
and I think that right now you're
finding consumers are feeling a little
bit better you know as some of these
policies sort of work their way through
the system you know we'll see how how
consumers react to them and so speaking
of the stock market it was kind of a
wacky
week so far that it's been up-down
up-down and pretty have they figured in
the people who buy and so on the stock
market have they figured in Black Friday
already
my guess is yes I mean I would say that
over for individual retailers obviously
it may be more volatile but you know for
things that happen um that are
predetermined such as we know Black
Friday's come in you know we knew the
Fed was going to make some sort of
statement on quantitative easing you
know that could be priced into the stock
market ahead of time and you typically
see just a little bit of balance after
the actual event but I would say the
individual retail stocks will vary
depending on how they do ray in
litchfield New Hampshire you're on the
Washington journal hi thank you for
taking my call my wife and I own a small
specialty retail shop and you know we
see definite you know excitement this
year a little bit increase in early
shopping people who are actually in
there shopping but we hope to come back
but you know we're expecting a good
Christmas this year but point I'm
hearing about by American and foreign
goods versus American goods we carry
probably 90% of the stuff we sell is
foreign based or foreign made but
because we we see it's hard to find
american-made products and Ray do you
look out for it do you try to find
american-made product we do we do and
you know it's it's tough to find
american-made goods for the things that
we sell that people can afford I mean
even products that are made in Europe
that we sell it is much more expensive
than products made over in Asia and we
get a lot of pushback from customers one
to know why these things are so
expensive and you know you make the
point that while it's made here in
America or you know made in Europe and
with the euro and the dollar and labor
costs from Europe being probably
equivalent to the US it's it's tough to
find reasonably priced products and
products made in US and Europe have a
much lower profit margin than what I can
get the same product in Europe and I
talk to other small business owners
especially shots and they say the same
thing they say that be it Footwear or
whatever that they get customers saying
why is this a hundred and eighty dollars
boo for one they can go to Walmart pick
this and get the same boot for fifty
dollars so you know again you know we
try to find american-made goods that
people can afford but it is very
difficult ray what kind of store do you
have in let's feel it's a small hobby
shop so a lot of the products that we
sell you know be it remote-control
products or plastic models those the
train sets there they're mostly made in
China now know are some goods that we
buy traditional erector sets made in
France but people they don't want to
spend seventy eighty a hundred dollars
on a toy like that and and finally ray
there's a big push for small businesses
you know kind of a promotion with
American Express and and the US
government has taken apart in this are
you taking a part in this promotion or
small business that I then you did sign
up for that and what American Express so
we're going to see how that plays out
tomorrow because it is you know what's a
geared for tomorrow to shop small
business all right
thanks right you thank you any response
to what he had to say well I thought he
had some really interesting points in
terms of again that question how much
you willing to pay for products that are
made in America can we even find
products that are made in America you
know can you find the american-made doll
can you find american-made a robotic toy
so I think that that was a really really
interesting perspective he had on it
because I think that part of what we
found is that stores like Walmart and
you know being able to easily access
cheap goods from overseas has lowered
the bar on what we expect to pay for
certain items we find that pricing is
pretty much relative you determine how
much a pair of socks cost by looking at
how much it costs at other stores and so
when the bar is lower that makes it more
difficult to pay more Hamden Connecticut
Anna good morning to you
good morning thanks for taking my call
say this is an hour-long conversation
for me but just a couple of bullet
points one is certainly big one is the
environmental impact that all our
consumerism is having on the world I
don't know that people really think
about what they buy versus the
destruction or corruption of
civilizations around the world you know
what are we buying from Walmart and what
is it what is the true price of it the
true cost sadly to another bullet point
is is there's no mom-and-pop stores left
well very few I truly tried to pass by
the large chain stores and to buy logo
and to buy this you know from somebody
who lives in the area where the money is
coming back into my community you know I
just think that people really need to
stop and really consider that the
Americans want cheap goods but they
really pay the true cost of those goods
Anna what are your plans this holiday
season when it comes to spending well
I'm a single mom couple of you know main
items for my daughter
probably a bicycle and you know we'll go
someplace fun and not spend money but
enjoy nature and the environment around
us visit family and friends are you
planning on spending more this year
absolutely not no no I'm really truly
you know I'm not gonna go to major chain
stores because really who do they look
out for they don't look out for me they
don't look out for you they look out for
their bottom line you know they want you
good they want to make a big profit of
it
I'll tell you I was and I won't mention
names but I was at a store and it was a
$200 jacket but I was able to find $15
deeply discounted I mean what did it
cost to make that jacket all right well
I think she brought up a good point
about the mom-and-pop stores and there
being fewer of them and then maybe there
were in olden days and you know and you
also brought up a small American Express
a small business Saturday which is the
first time that there's been a sort of
effort backed by obviously a national
card company to
promote small businesses and to get
folks shopping and when I spoke to make
Express about this I said you know why
she's I she's Saturday why don't you try
to do Friday or a different day and they
said they understood that actually the
small businesses would not be able to
compete with the types of discounts and
promotions that the big-box stores and
the major chains are going to be
offering today and so they decide to do
it the day after because they felt that
way they would get more attention and
more folks would be likely to go to
their to their local retailer now there
was some legislation as well passed to
assist small businesses in the last
couple of months yes so Congress has
passed legislation that provides tax
incentives for small businesses also
makes it easier for them to borrow money
to fund whatever needs they may have
whatever capital investments they may be
doing so that is something that Congress
passed to support small businesses
because small businesses account for
about two thirds of new jobs that are
created so they are immensely important
to the labor market
however you know whether or not we see
these policies actually result in new
hiring is still up for debate because
what small businesses are finding is
that we're not gonna hire if we don't
see customers coming through the door at
the bottom at the bottom line is we need
to see that demand in order to pick up
the employment say in Baltimore emails
in when did the US economy become
dependent on consumer spending our
family never purchased anything that was
not a necessity never went to the mall
and what's absolutely necessary you've
really seen the rise of the consumer I
believe it has closely tracked the rise
of credit you know starting in the 70s
when we were able to to spend in a way
that we hadn't before when credit became
more accessible I believe that is when
when consumers sort of rose in
importance however in terms of the exact
breakdown of GDP I can't tell you that
and this is from Ruth just as Miss Mui
says if you don't come out and buy you
might see an increase in unemployment so
it's all back to consumer confidence
from the professional business reporter
which ignores that there cannot be
consumption without disposable income
making this a which is first the chicken
or the egg and the professional chooses
consumer egg to crack open however
accuracy businesses prospered and should
be the chance taker to open up the
economy if I'm following the email
correctly I think what they're saying is
that you need money to be able to spend
right so we have seen a slight uptick in
wages we are seeing some increase in in
consumers ability to spend and we it's
clear that they have money it's just in
savings
so the question again goes back to that
paradox of thrift how much of that are
we actually going to to use versus how
much are we going to be putting aside
for a rainy day
Bruce tweets in what effect does bush
tax cut extension in limbo
have on holiday spending well I would I
can speak to this from a personal level
we actually did a chart recently why I
believe it ran but we put together a
chart that showed the potential tax
increase for the average household in
different income bracket brackets if the
if the tax cuts are not extended and
they are high I mean the potential
impact on households are hot how friend
of mine is that to an everyday consumer
that is unclear but I think it may add
to the uncertainty that people feel
about the economic recovery and what is
gonna happen over the next six months
next call comes from Jacksonville
Florida
go ahead Pat Republican life thank you
thank you for taking my call and I
really appreciate this young reporter
coming on and listening to the feedback
that she's getting from concerned
Americans and I hope she takes it back
to her editors because the Washington
Post is one of the newspapers that if
anyone says like in the United States
not used tariffs to protect our economy
they're immediately called protectionist
the Washington Post did not cover that
when President Obama went to India to
what two weeks ago he was going there
trying to get them to open up their
markets India closes their market to us
as this China China does it with a
devalued currency and yet that is fine
we have a situation where the European
government they have a 21 percent back
tack
they use that as a tariff on any
American product that comes into Europe
they use it as a subsidy as anything
that comes in just comes into the United
States if you go to Target those things
are subsidized because that the
Washington Post knows that they know
that an economy grows wealth by
industrial production small businesses
grow their wealth from industrial
production when people have the money
well I I can't speak for our editorial
pages and what they may what positions
they may take on certain issues but
certainly I would say that you know we
always try to cover as many angles as
possible whether it's about and the
president's trip to India or about our
trip to the store a few minutes left
with our guest elan movie of The
Washington Post another call from
Jacksonville Florida this from Jeff on
our Democrats line and it sounds like
Jeff has gone bye-bye Joseph and Camden
South Carolina hi Joseph
your gift it shows choice by showing him
inflation is pretty low and how people's
wages is going up and so forth well I'm
all social security in for two years
your gift
that food prices is going down well I
would like to know where she do her
shopping because you're in the South
Carolina area and as well as in some of
your new years in area where my daughter
will our food prices has went up
big-time and so I would just like to
know where you'll get her shopping thank
you
well I I shop at Harris Teeter in
Safeway and jaian or the major grocery
stores in the Washington area and you
know I I can't speak to what prices they
may be paying at that particular store
but if you look on the aggregate you're
finding that the food prices overall and
the Consumer Price Index have come down
and again it depends on what comparison
you're making they've come down from
highs that we saw in 2008 they may be a
little higher than they were last month
so you know these things change
frequently as commodity prices change
Jean tweets in I've been
New Balance athletic shoes for years now
because they are made in America and
they are of superior quality East Lake
Ohio
Jackie Democrat you're on the Washington
journal Peter why doesn't she
expel the cheap items that come in from
China you're washing t-shirt wants and
it falls apart kids wear their jeans a
couple of times and the zippers break a
mom goes out to buy a $30 jacket at
Walmart and of course the zipper doesn't
work and and the kid is walking around
for the rest of the winter with his
jacket open you know these things
started in in the 80s when we decided
that that we didn't want to be workers
anymore we wanted to because the
powers-that-be wanted us to be consumers
they didn't want us to be worker bees
anymore
they wanted their they wanted their cake
and they wanted to eat it too so they've
done so average wages have gone down
since the 80s our employment is stagnant
we've had higher unemployment since the
80s and and you you said they're so
happily talking about this stuff and and
what happens is that we're becoming a
third world nation we don't make
anything we don't take pride in anything
all right Jackie we're going to leave it
there Ilan Mui is our personal income
according when you look at the the macro
figures these figures are going up again
so there there's a difference between
what's happening on a macro level what's
happening on a micro level so macro you
know you are seeing slight very slight
increases in personal income and in
wages but however as we talked about
earlier you are seeing a sort of
bifurcation in the American consumer
where the affluent consumer has returned
in a way that consumers in the lower and
middle classes have not and and that's
something that I think you can hear from
the retailers when they talk about it in
their earnings and they
say you know we're still seeing people
line up at midnight outside our doors so
waiting for their unemployment benefits
starts they can buy baby formula you
know those are very powerful stories
that show that there still is immense
strain on a certain segment of the
consumer population Ilan Moo is with the
Washington Post thank you for being on
the Washington journal thank you